if i loved you
not the woman that i'm trying to make
you be what is
happening right now i think it's a
beautiful day to save lives don't you
agree
i'm gonna like being married it's the
wedding part that's ridiculous
oh party's over you know what's funny
even though the show was filmed so long
ago
this scene of them have it hanging
around and having pagers
still rings true all my residents still
carry their beepers around
and they get paid and they have to
interrupt what they're doing to go
respond to an emergency now we're not
surgical residents we're family medicine
residents
but equally as important just on
different terms you marrying burke
it's a sign sign that people like you
and me
can do this be healthy be happy did she
just steal
my line in the show they found the
fourth climber
vitals are stabilizing after fluids but
i thought he was dead it was according
to his friends did the ct show a bleed
uh we haven't done a ct yes understood
you said there's a headphone
yeah there's been a little head trauma
ice axe to the head
oh so you really need a probably a
neurosurgery consult at this point
for having an ice pick stuck in this
gentleman's head now
as i told you earlier on this channel if
you ever get hip with
something and it stays inserted into you
a knife
ice pick whatever it is you don't take
it out because it's putting pressure on
there to prevent you from bleeding out
so if you take that ice pick out
what's going to happen the person is
going to bleed especially from the skull
if you ever needed to get staples placed
in your scalp because you cut yourself
you know how much it bleeds even the
smallest little cut on the scalp bleeds
a tremendous amount it's actually really
scary
but it's only because there's a lot of
blood supply to that area not because
there's a lot of
damage to that area so just keep that in
mind my wife came into my hospital and
you neglected to tell me about your
patient confidentiality
it's actually a very difficult place to
find yourself because if you
have one of your colleagues family
members as your patient
you want to share and you feel like you
should be able to share but in reality
you can't
i actually treat a lot of my colleagues
even my attendings when i was a resident
their children and as a result the
things that their
children tell me i can't share with them
only when they're brought into the room
by the patient
or the patient expressed the fact that i
can discuss their case with them
do i then incorporate them into into the
conversation
but in reality it's two separate people
just because i know both of you doesn't
mean i can freely talk about your care
to one another there's some things we
share with our families some things we
don't and
that's a right she's unconscious there
are medical decisions to be made
legally i have the right to know i have
a right i might
be having a miscarriage what's wrong
with me
i'm gonna explain everything to you i
promise right now
we need to get you up to the surgical
floor surgery
what about my babies well i think those
babies are coming out today
but i haven't decided
i haven't chosen parents i need time to
decide
it looked like he was doing an
ultrasound of her heart which is an
echocardiogram i didn't follow the case
from the previous story but
sounds like she's pregnant and she's
acting as a surrogate to give the child
to one of the two families there
i wonder what can be going on with her
heart that they need to take her for an
operation
the medical curiosity in me is a pekin
how's reena
i need to get a ct angel but i'm pretty
sure it's a tear in our aorta
her heart is about to blow whoa so uh
dissecting aortic aneurysm is when there
is an aneurysm
within the aorta which is the largest
blood vessel that comes off of the heart
and brings blood to the rest of your
body
an aneurysm first of all is a weakness
in the wall where it actually protrudes
out
so if you imagine your artery being like
a balloon
and then one area of the balloon is very
weak so it creates almost like an
owl pouching when that happens that wall
is very susceptible to bursting and
rupturing because it doesn't have
all the layers that the rest of the uh
artery has
so what can happen is you could have a
dissecting aortic aneurysm
where it's getting so bad that that weak
arterial wall is literally about to
burst
and that patient can rightfully bleed
out and die because of all the bleeding
internally
so you have to go for surgery
immediately i just don't know how this
is happening in such a calm
situation because it's really a medical
emergency or surgical emergency where
you need to go go go and start the
operation
i didn't paid you go home get some sleep
yeah but i'm here already
you're getting married in less than 12
hours
well uh brooke's getting married too and
he gets to operate there's only one
kristen burke
there's only one christina yang i've
given you the day off
the whole day it's a kindness take it
it's your wedding day there'll always be
more surgeries but
really what would you rather be doing
prepping a patient or prepping for your
wedding go home
those who love our jobs and who are
passionate about our jobs
we want to be there but it's at times we
have to pump the brakes
and realize that if we want to perform
better at work it's actually ideal to
take some time off
this is why one of the biggest problems
that people
face is that as they make more money you
would think they would become more
financially independent therefore take
more time off but in reality they just
become slaves to their money into their
job
it's really important to not burn out
because too many people in our society
right now are working day in and day out
and there's times we need to do that
and we need to put our foot down but
then there's also times where we
understand that a break will actually
yield
better results they recovered london's
body
not his body he's alive
so why don't you tell me what really
happened up there on the mountain so i'm
assuming
because i don't know a lot about this
case they're on a mountain they were
trapped there's frostbite happening
frostbite generally happens on areas
that have
less circulation and areas that only
have less circulation but are ones that
your body will decrease blood flow to in
order to conserve
warmth so for example if you ever see
your hands get
blue when you're really cold that's your
body naturally protecting yourself from
losing heat
what it does is redirects the blood back
to your core so that you stay warm your
vital organs stay well perfused with
blood flow
and you don't need a lot of blood flow
to keep your hands alive so if they look
blue that's what's happening there's
also a condition called raynaud's
phenomenon
you have an ultrasensitive reaction to
cold
so just being in a cold in a cold
location for a short period of time will
make your hands turn blue a simple task
for that is to put your hand in cold
water and i'm not recommending you do
this but you could put your
hand in cold water and take it right out
if your hand turns blue really quickly
you have what's known as ray
it's an accident
i feel like it's not mcdreamy's place to
make the decision on whether or not it
was an accident in this scenario if i
have people talking about
self-harm or i don't know what you would
call this like an assault
type situation even if you think it may
be on accident or self-defense you have
to get the authorities involved i think
that's the ideal situation
maybe not right in this moment because
no one's escaping here they all look
really injured
but at some point you have to get
authorities involved so should i be
worried or something should you be
worried that i met a woman
no should you be worried that for me
flirting with that woman was a highlight
of my week
yeah you should be one or something
[Music]
what kind of threat was that that's
manipulative mcdreamy
don't do that i just checked chief
president hasn't been posted yet no no i
wasn't looking for tv yeah you were
yeah okay i was for those of you who
don't know chief resident is a really
important position
even more important when you're a
surgical resident i'll give an example
in family medicine
the senior attendings all sit together
on a committee and nominate who's going
to be the chief resident
generally the way it works is the chief
resident in their last year of residency
takes on the additional role
of doing all the scheduling all the
organizing of the rest of the junior
residents
in internal medicine they may actually
stay on for a fourth additional year
to do that consult on difficult cases
work in specialties that they feel they
need more help in
or they use it as an opportunity to
showcase themselves
for fellowship positions that they may
have not gotten or to make themselves
more competitive
in the upcoming uh match very
prestigious but
very difficult uh to be successful at
housing a human
for nine long months is all that i can
think about
the thoughts are invading the surgeries
that i love and it's it's
it's it's hormonal it's it's and
horrible
but it is happening to me
you want to have a baby did one resident
just ask
another resident to impregnate her
because she wants a baby
i hope i'm missing something and they're
actually in a long-term relationship and
that was their way of talking about it
pressure's dropped to 60. she's braiding
it down edison how much momentum rough
showing the memory now i just need two
minutes to get these babies out make it
one she's flatlined steven start
compressions
yay they're starting chest compressions
before shocking the patient first i'm
sorry i'm so
excited that a patient's flatlining but
i'm just happy that he said start chest
compressions before whipping out the
machines a shock clamp
second baby's out okay oh my god but
look at those horrible
compressions happening in the background
oh my god
the doctors they're going like this hold
up
that is not a hundred beats per minute
that's not two inches deep chest
compressions chest compression chest
compressions i feel like i'm yelling at
every video
is he gonna wake up do you want him to
what the axe in his head was put there
deliberately
i just want to give you three guys
another opportunity to tell me the truth
you're not a cop oh what's going on she
started cramping and then she got really
diaphoretic
alert will be to a possible dnc due to
an incomplete miscarriage
so a dnc is a dilation in curettage but
it's basically a medical procedure to
uh get the uterine contents out that can
be really important if there is bleeding
going on you're trying to figure out
where the source of bleeding is coming
from this is something you need to do
very urgently
i understand why because this patient is
bleeding out diaphoretic
cramping cramping means that there's
bleeding probably happening in the
uterine cavity we need to diagnose and
treat it simultaneously with a dnc she
went into early dic
i gave her blood platelets ffp
pregnancy at 52 is dangerous i tried
everything i
couldn't save
oh wow oh
all the babies oh i thought
i thought for a second i thought i'd
lost
i thought he lost her too because dic
can be a very deadly and quickly deadly
condition it stands for disseminated
intravascular
coagulation it's basically when inside
your blood
you use up all the clotting factors and
you start clotting
so two things happen the more platelets
you have the more clotting that happens
but then you also use up all your
platelets so that you can bleed from
other areas
very unique situation there's very
specific protocols we have to follow
in order to make sure these patients a
don't bleed out and b don't form clots
in areas where they can be life
threatening brain heart lungs etc i
think that might have been the best
explanation of dic i've ever given in my
life
it's a much better man than i thought
he'll get over his initial judgments and
he'll
sit with you is it him
and he'll make you drink your water
he's the papa bear i mean sad that he
lost a child
god all right i gotta really adjust my
emotions because i'm your best friend
because i love you
i also have to say
that i'm in love with you i officially
want to check
what they're pumping in to the air
conditioning units
in seattle grace's whatever the name of
this hospital is
i don't know if they're pumping
pheromones in there angel cupid arrows
everyone's in love with everybody
everyone wants to cheat on everybody
people want to get married they don't
want to get married they want to pay
what
this is the most dysfunctional group of
humans i've ever seen
i want you to give me a reason to stay
even the
patients are falling in love with the
doctors i can't even i lost count of how
many love
triangles and circles and squares i feel
like in order to understand their
relationships fully i got to bring out
the pythagorean theorem on this one i
mean
for god's sakes grey's anatomy keep it
together you don't want me
maybe i do no you don't
you want ava she's not ava anymore
i know why this is one of the top fan
favorite episodes
because everyone's in love with every
it's it's something about weddings
or is this every grey's anatomy episode
for some reason every episode i watched
before
there's a lot of medical stuff a little
bit of romance this is everyone is
on top of everybody all the time i'm up
there waiting for you to come down the
aisle
and i know you don't want to come i know
you don't want to come
but that you'll come anyway because you
love me
and if i loved you if i loved
you not the woman that i'm trying to
make you be not the woman that i hope
what is happening right now did they
need to make everything more dramatic
than it needs to be
you decide to get married you love each
other but the person's hesitant
so now you're being worried that they're
hesitant and your love
contradicts their love he should just
change the name of this episode so dr
mike loses his mind over grey's anatomy
instead of react
there's no reacting i'm just losing my
mind at this point i feel like you guys
missed out my latest
medical memes review and my hospital
vlog so if you did click one of those
bad boys and as always stay happy and
[Music]
healthy